welcome to episode 100 of the michaela
peterson podcast i decided to do a q a
because i haven't done a q a before so i
thought that might be kind of special
i've also been
ridiculously busy super stressed and i
had to reschedule a few podcasts that i
thought would be appropriate for episode
100 and so
they're not getting released yet so
they're going to be after episode 100 so
for now
you guys get a q a from me thank you
guys so much for watching
here we go
[Music]
okay first what am i up to i'm building
an
app with my dad with his grad student
with andre
this grad students named victor the app
is going to be called aim
and it's for increasing resilience you
can identify areas in your life
that you're not happy with and then
figure it figure out what
in that area you're not happy with make
a to-do list and start checking things
off and improving areas of your life
this is a very simplified version
hopefully my ads will be
better than that but i'm hoping it'll be
able to increase people's resilience
there's a lot of neuroscience behind it
my dad's into it
victor's super smart and i'm building it
to help myself
sort out my own life and increase my
resilience so i'm really excited for
that that's called aim
that's probably going to take another
four months at least realistically i
am almost on my electrolytes maybe
that's for september
there's a tart cherry flavor salted
caramel they have
very pure ingredients because i'm a
sensitive human being i've worked on
them for two years
turns out making pure electrolytes was
really tricky
those are coming out lion electrolytes i
really want to
make a hangover pill there's this
compound called dihydromyricitin
that fixes my hangovers i'd really like
to do something with that so maybe
there's that in the future the pouting
barbie merch is coming
at some point merch is coming there's
also going to be a t-shirt that says wow
instead of some intellectual quote it's
just wow my websites are coming out
lion diet.com is going to come out
michaela peterson is getting revamped
i've almost completely outsourced my
dad's work
so there's a whole bunch of people on
his side now and i'm kind of just
overseeing that still recording ads so
i've almost completely stepped away from
managing my dad's stuff which is
fantastic because i have so much going
on on my side
and then i also came home because he's
not feeling well so i've been home
taking care of him
that is what i have been up to what's
your big five score
okay i can pull this up you guys ready
big five score so you can go to
this is just i'm gonna just throw
another ad in there uh
understandmyself.com
my dad made a personality test you've
probably heard me talk about that i am
obsessed with i used to make people i
dated take it before i dated them
although i'd still date them it didn't
really matter it's like oh a psychopath
a good idea
not agreeableness 20th percentile
agreeableness breaks down into
compassion
and politeness i scored zero percentile
in politeness
and 81 percentile in compassion so very
high in compassion
if there were 100 people in the room i
would be more compassionate than 81 of
them
and i would be more polite than zero of
them
makes me chuckle conscientiousness 85th
percentile it breaks down into
industriousness which i had 85th
percentile on
and orderliness which i hit 76th
percentile
on so that's super high in both
extroversion 99th percentile that breaks
into enthusiasm which i got 96
percentile in and assertiveness 99th
percentile
that's very assertive the average
assertiveness
for men is 52 and i'm 99.
neuroticism moderately high 67th
percentile
withdrawal was very low 10th percentile
and volatility was 97th
zero percentile in politeness and 97th
percentile in volatility to be fair
i don't think i would have been that
volatile but i think taking ssris for a
decade and a bit increased my volatility
a little bit and i've been
super stressed a little traumatized but
i think it
improves my sense of humor openness to
experience 87th
that breaks into intellect 94th
percentile and
openness 63rd percentile that is
my big five if you guys want to take it
you can use code mp
for like two dollars off but it's only
ten dollars or something like that
and it's really interesting gives you a
whole bunch of information have you
become friends with any of your podcast
guests
yeah actually i've had a lot of the
guests on because they're my friends
but most of them know so max lugavir i
meant i met before
our podcasts he's actually coming up
again i would consider him a friend
uh hamilton morris definitely like
texting basis
occasionally when i have relevant
questions chris williamson
i'm good friends with him nicole arbour
i just went out for drinks with her
i will be going to a young gravy concert
i can't say that we're friends but
i did tell him about the hangover pills
that i will make one day
james smith i had on i'd consider him a
friend
lewis howes michelle romano i will
definitely be going to dan crenshaw's
fourth of july party next year tucker
max
tom bill you we've texted anyway
business ideas mostly
lauren southern peripherally friends
gregor gallagher there's some so yes a
lot of them
i can't believe how great it is to have
a podcast to meet people
to have them on the show to stay in
touch afterwards it's insane
to be able to connect with people that
way i'm feeling very blessed what was it
like growing up with jordan as your
dad my dad is really a lot like he is on
youtube
if you've seen any of his lectures or
looked at his old courses
that was kind of what dinner table
conversation was like so
i learned a lot about psychology way
more than i
knew i knew i guess i know a lot about
personality i did
sit in on some of his courses when i was
in high school though skip in high
school
for university personality courses what
was it like it was
i didn't know it was weird until i was
like 24 or until he got famous
and then i realized it was weird and it
was weird our house was filled with
soviet art
filled i once had a lenin painting fall
on me while i was sleeping we had 37
different
colors of paint in our house over 100
paintings all the walls were completely
covered in soviet art
some native carvings and there was other
art in there
so what was it like it was i learned a
ton he's
weird i'm weird i'm not sure what it was
like imagine if your entire childhood
you spent watching
jordan peterson youtube videos so that
have you ever played video games
have i played no yes actually that is
not true
i played guitar hero a lot like a lot in
grade
10 enough that i can still play on
expert which is kind of embarrassing if
i'd spent that many hours
trying to learn a guitar i would know
how to play the guitar but instead i
know how to play guitar hero
what is your opinion on having friends
with polar opposite political and social
views
i think it's good to surround yourself
with people who don't agree with you
because you're not going to be right
about everything and you have to stay
open-minded however i don't know if i
could stand
being good friends with someone with
polar opposite political views
i have friends that are liberal we get
into arguments sometimes if we're
drinking
it's fun we still like each other
surround yourself with people who don't
agree with you but complete polar
opposites i don't know if that would
make a good friendship are you going to
release a book in the future what would
it be about
yes i am i actually just finished my
book it's going to be called
could be worse which some people gave me
[ __ ] for they're like oh there's like
there's people that are really suffering
[ __ ] you guys do you still have both
your hips can i swear on youtube yeah i
can swear on youtube i have a podcast
uh so the book is going to be coming out
i spent
my entire life writing it obviously it's
edited down but i've been keeping a
journal since i was in grade one to
handle my
major depression which doesn't exist
anymore thank goodness
and so i've kept track of everything
i've been through my memory is
absolutely ridiculous
i could remember parts of my childhood
that i shouldn't remember and i think
partially it's because i wrote
everything down
so i've written that all into a book it
goes up until
december 2019. that's when it ends and
then i'm going to be writing a book
about what happened after that that a
lot of that was my dad's health stuff
and
that was just way too much to put into
one book so it's going to be about my
autoimmune disorder how
i came to the diet i'm on uh the
all-meat diet
lion diet which i still get a kick out
of i can't believe i called it the lion
diet
perfect anyway so it's about that it's
about getting off of ssris it's about
how weird my life has been
relationships i'm hoping it'll help
people it's
it's a lot of it's about the mindset i
needed in order to get healthy
the kind of brain changes i needed to
make my mind
in order to convince myself to start
trying to get healthy
so a lot of it is that and that's gonna
be coming out i'm hoping like
early next year has your experience
getting covered twice changed your
opinion regarding lockdowns
no no not at all lockdowns are
ridiculous
they just came out with information that
they've caused more deaths to people
under
oof i better check this i'm going to say
65 to be safe it might have been 85
say 65 caused more deaths than young
people the lockdowns
than kovit did shockingly not at all
right
uh opiate deaths are way up in canada
and the u.s they're finally coming out
with stats so no
i think that the whole coveted situation
is terrible it's obviously
a bad virus i've had it twice the second
time was bad i don't get sick very often
so
it's bad do you lock down the economy
and force people to stay at home
and isolate people and increase opiate
deaths and increase the
amount of benzodiazepines that are being
prescribed and ssris which are
extremely dependents forming that nobody
knows about so we're gonna have
generations of people who can't get off
of meds now
no i don't think you take away people's
civil liberties
as a government i don't think that's
fair and i don't think the government is
smart enough to be making those
decisions but i wouldn't recommend
getting covered twice
how are your r.a symptoms arthritis
symptoms on your diet after so many
years
uh my ra symptoms are non-existent if i
get a virus
my right wrist gets kind of cracky like
so it's been a little bit
iffy since covet my covid symptoms
lasted quite a while like i was negative
i
tested negative for a long time but i've
had a stuffy nose
since i had coped which is really
annoying so i've been sleeping sitting
up because i have a stuffy nose
which they're i mean people have way
worse symptoms but my wrist was like a
little iffy after covet other than
that i used to have arthritis all over
my body i had my hip and ankle replaced
my
right toe was really bad both my
shoulders were really difficult to sleep
on i had to take painkillers at night i
did my knees
i had it almost everywhere except for my
spine and now if i get a virus
it'll flare up like my right wrist will
be a little bit sore
sometimes i can feel it my toe with a
virus but other than that with a diet
it's been
amazing i've been in remission almost
consistently since i was
23. um give or take a few months when i
got
pregnant and then my symptoms came back
but there's a reason i'm still on the
diet and a big part of it is because my
body eats my joints when i eat
yummy foods how do you grow your podcast
audience
i talk about things i like and i talk
about to people
who i think are interesting and i put
out clips and i record consistently
i think recording consistently is really
important i have all the social medias
well not all of them
but i have most of the big ones and i
just do my thang in which ways is
scarlett like you and not like you
scarlett is going to before she's my
child she
has a fantastic sense of humor and that
is obviously from me
she's a lot more girly as a i know i'm
here blonde wearing a pink dress but i
didn't wear a dress until
i was in grade seven or eight past grade
one when my parents forced me to wear
this poofy
pink sleeve dress and i refused to wear
a dress after that i was not impressed
so she's i guess she's younger but still
like her favorite color is pink through
and through
she wants her nails done all the time
she wants lipstick she's four
she when she runs she like runs like a
little fairy and holds her dress out
she was called pocahontas for the for
almost her entire third year
because she was like no i am pocahontas
uh she's stubborn which
i think she's more stubborn than i was
when i was little too i wasn't that
stubborn how is she like me
she says wow all the time she was
undoing those what are those little
dolls called i should know this
russian those russian stacking dolls
matroshka
matrushka yeesh that's going to be
embarrassing for people who
know the right word she was unstacking
those and every time she opened one
she's like wow
opens another one wow wow it's so weird
to have a little tiny like princess
child running around going wow i like
her you guys should have children
they're really awesome they're also a
hell of a lot of work and they make you
cry
sometimes but they're so cool they get
so much cooler when they get older too
what does a day in your life look like
it's been pretty random because we were
traveling a lot i wanted to get out of
canada because
i'd been cooped up in this condo like
this is podcast studios where i spent
most of my time there's no windows it
was like vitamin d deficient i was
stressed out
everything was locked down so i wanted
to get out of canada so we were
traveling around a lot
so i didn't really have a usual day what
my day looks like now
is scarlett's in school she goes to a
montessori
daycare my audience is like probably
going to be like me take care of me
but she really likes daycare she's a
very social child she wants to see
friends
so she goes to montessori and she likes
it so [ __ ] you guys
but anyway she goes to daycare if it's a
super busy day i will record
a podcast at 11am and at 1pm i try to
batch them so
i try to do like a whole bunch for three
weeks and then i won't do anything for a
few months which means they end up a
little bit aged sometimes
i'll probably figure out a better way to
do that i'd like to do them live but
anyway i'll do like two podcasts so
today i did
two podcasts i'm doing this q a doing
therapy afterwards
hanging with scarlet eating dinner
watching something to try and turn
my brain off and going to bed at around
11. i've been having trouble sleeping
because i have been super stressed out
because my dad's not
feeling well so this morning for
instance i woke up at 5 30 in the
morning and then i didn't go back to
sleep
so it depends on the night that's also
why i talk to a lot of sleep
people on my podcast because i'm like
how do i hack this
better but it turns out just not being
under overwhelming stress is part of the
key to sleeping well and i haven't got
that under control yet oh
eating of course people eat during the
day too i
have only had part of a frozen sausage
today
because this was a really busy day so
this will probably be a one meal or
maybe a two later meals
day but because of the diet because i
don't need any carbs i don't have to eat
very often i don't usually eat when i
first get up
i'll have tea i can drink tea now whoa
black
tea whoa guys so i have like a tiny bit
of caffeine
um oh and i also exercised this morning
wow clearly i've never done a day in my
life because i'm going all over the
place
i actually i didn't sleep i woke up i
had to cry because i was stressed out
about something then i felt better
then i did a bunch of exercise then i
put on my makeup then i did well i did
one podcast then i did the intro for my
dad's podcast and i wrote that ad
and intro then i did another podcast
then i'm doing the q a i'm having some
tea
talking to a therapist seeing scarlet
maybe i'll have some soup
that is my day are you sick of lobsters
yet
i'm never going to be sick of lobsters i
literally dressed up as a lobster for
halloween which some people thought i
did
seriously they're like isn't this weird
yeah it's weird
a sexy lobster yeah it's weird people
with no sense of humor
shouldn't follow me i'm never going to
get tired of lobsters please please keep
sending them i got sent
a picture of a cloud that looked like a
lobster it full-on did look like lobster
they're just like
look at this cloud the thought of you
thank you clouds that look like lobsters
weird who's the most attractive member
of your team asked by
real life ben that's inappropriate ben
is my social media guy
slash right hand human i have a number
of people who help me now actually
which is makes things so much easier
it's so much easier i have somebody who
is now
like scheduling my calendar following up
with people
doing the admin part i have ben who does
social media he'll post clips he makes
the some of the
graphics if they're in quotes forms he's
helped do the website
he's looking at merch he's amazing he's
done more than that but
that's off the top of my head eric has
been helping me with my podcast
for over a year it's been almost a year
and a half that's quite a few people
andre helps with business and contracts
some of them that's more on the luminate
side actually
i have help now which is crazy it's
crazy how much more you can do when you
have help
skin care routine this is going to
resonate with my mostly male audience
skincare routine
honestly it's my diet really it's my all
meat diet
actually there's also this moisturizer i
use that's probably worth seven dollars
called cerave
it's the best moisturizer i've ever used
so i moisturize
all over my face before i go to bed i
use lanolin as well which is like
some horrible like sheep oil it's
something gross but it works really well
and i was scared of reacting to things i
put on my mouth when i was
sicker i'm not as scared of that anymore
but so i've been using lanolin for years
so that i also use a hyaluronic acid
moisturizer before i go to bed but um my
skin
is mostly my diet like if i get sick my
skin will break out a bit
if i drink too much it'll break out a
bit if i eat chicken
or too much honey it'll break out a bit
isn't that sad
oh well whatever no it's kind of sad
actually chicken wings are great
chicken wings are great how do you
manage to do so many things at the same
time
i don't think it's good necessarily like
when i'm going to sleep at night
i'll be trying to fall asleep and i'll
have something i haven't done
pop into my head and then i'll open my
phone which is beside my bed which it
shouldn't be i should
switch back i used to be using a notepad
one of those ones i used to advertise
murty
i used to be using a murty journal and
writing down these things that would pop
into my head but i'll go to sleep be
like oh
follow up with hangover pill people
forgot about that for the last week
follow up with merch follow up with i
have so many different projects going on
we just got a
ux person for the aim app i haven't had
time to
edit my book which i want to send to the
editor so i can get it out
so how do i manage to do so many things
i think i have so many things i'm doing
spread out in so many different areas
like all i've been talking about now is
what i'm doing on my side
like i said i've mostly outsourced
luminate which is my dad's company
mostly outsourced that work thank
goodness but there's still oversight of
all that
and investments and relationships to
keep track of and oh i didn't follow up
with this person
it's really hard it's really hard and
i'm
exhausted and i'm working all the time
like last night i was preparing for the
podcast today because i was really
looking forward to
i had dr carolyn leaf and dr daniel
ayman and they're talking about brain
health and i was
i really wanted to do those so i thought
i could pick up some tidbits that might
help my dad
or me so i spent three hours preparing
for them yesterday
went to bed and i'm going to be working
from
8 30 to 5 30 today which is actually
pretty good normally i'd be working in
the evening too but i think i can take
the evening off
so i manage it because i'm healthy and i
spent so much of my life like i
when i was in high school i used to
sleep in the morning and then come home
after school and sleep and then eat
dinner and then sleep and then wake up
and i was just tired all the time and i
didn't have any energy for anything and
now
i'm healthy and i have so much energy
and i'm super stressed
with family health things and some other
like aspects of my life need more
sorting out perhaps my app can help me
with that anyway
so i enjoy it really i like working i
also
have a problem that when i get stressed
i bury myself in work because work makes
me feel better which is good
you want work that makes you feel good
but you don't want to avoid other
aspects of your life that are
problematic because working feels better
than
identifying those aspects and correcting
them which i also tend to do
occasionally i don't know i scored high
in industriousness maybe that's it
okay few more questions oh i like this
one
what's the worst steak you've ever had
okay
so was in russia and i had a difficult
time
sourcing good quality food in russia and
good quality meat they full-on
use some spray on their meat that i
react to so it was really hard to find
meat that hadn't been sprayed because
they sprayed at the butchers
or at the slaughterhouse so we had to go
to a farm and get meat that i didn't
react to it was a huge pain
anyway we bought this cow we had this
cow we ordered meat from the cow
but we didn't directly go to pick it up
so someone else brought meat so i had
one of these steaks
woke up at four in the morning with
really horrible food poisoning
called them the next day and they're
like oh yeah sorry that was for a
restaurant a restaurant sorry we meant
to send that to the restaurant
like first of all what restaurants i can
never go there because i just
was violently ill this was the day
before i had to fly home
with the remnants of kovid really and it
wasn't covet it was the steak
so yeah it was meant for a restaurant
and which it definitely wasn't they
definitely just
stole the cow and gave us crappy steak
that was the worst steak i've had
parenting topics how do you discipline
okay so when i grew up i would say
my parents were pretty strict discipline
was definitely things like don't let
your kids do anything it makes you not
like them
which is true you do not want to let
your kids run all over you and it's good
to have boundaries or your kids are
unhappy so we have boundaries
right it's like putting them to bed on
time no i don't want to go to bed okay
if you don't go to bed
you're going to be upset tomorrow you're
going to wreck your day and you need to
go to sleep because it's healthy for
your brain
so that is a boundary you're going to
bed no questions asked if you're
very very firm with your rules and you
don't move
them ever then kids especially little
kids follow those rules
if you end up moving them you're like
yeah okay well tonight you can stay up
or if they push a certain number of
times they'll be like please please
please please please please please
please get to seven you're like ah [ __ ]
it fine
then next time they'll just move their
level to seven so seven will be the
minimum times they ask for something
so have firm boundaries i've been taking
care of kids since i was pretty little i
used to go
in the summer and take care of my
cousins and they were when they were
about three
and four maybe two and three so i've got
some experience with kids other than
having a four-year-old but
i think a lot of it comes down to gonna
say this but
not feeding them crap food if your kid
eats a whole bunch of sugar
that's not good for their brain they're
gonna be running around shrieking
hitting things and then what you're
gonna be disciplining them because
they're sugar high
honestly scarlett is an angel she's
stubborn but she's super smart she's
super funny and she's
really calm we travel all over the world
when i bring over a babysitter you know
how i was always scared i was going to
have this kid that just like grabs onto
my leg and is like no
don't leave or like dropping them off at
daycare and they're just
shrieking something horrible like that
and then they're traumatized you're
traumatized
that's probably the people that get
screwed up at daycares when they're like
no mom where are you going
well scarlett we bring over a babysitter
and she's just like yep come this way
look at my dress
aren't i cute and then they play if we
drop her off at daycare
walk her to daycare she gets an apricot
before she goes inside takes her apricot
leaves she'll do hugs sometimes but it's
not and it's not lack of love she's just
happy to be going wherever she's going
and i think a lot of that has to do with
not feeding her like she doesn't eat any
sugar none
ever she had sugar one time it was in a
sausage my mom bought
and she screamed afterwards like one of
those toddlers in an airport where you
kind of want to kill their parents
and so i was like never never again she
has honey that doesn't seem to matter
but she doesn't have any cane sugar
um we don't do dairy she basically eats
meat
and fruit and vegetables which people
might be like oh
what about you know but i don't care
about those people because i have a
perfect child
are you more like your mom or your dad
so personality wise i'm more like my dad
for sure i also look more like my dad
than my brother who looks
way more like my mom it's crazy we did
23 and me and i am actually more
related to my dad than i am to my mom
isn't that weird my brother is more
related to my mom and he looks like my
mom
you know i guess it's not weird when you
say it that way i just didn't realize
that you could
have like it's like a good portion more
dna towards one parent
than another parent although to be
honest scarlet looks like andre
it's really annoying although at least
she got blue eyes but still like i
birthed
you that's not fair anyway i'm more
personality wise like my
dad but i'm open like my mom so all that
like hippie woo-woo stuff my dad would
never ever ever ever even close to
believe any of that even the stuff that
he should be more inclined to believe so
i've got the openness for my mom but
i've got the extreme skepticism from my
dad which gives me a strange personality
the volatility comes from my dad
uh the industriousness comes from my dad
orderliness is mum
compassion is dad he's super super
compassionate zero politeness
that's my mom that's so cool you guys
should do personality things not because
my dad sells them but because they're
actually
really interesting and i think on the
website now which is kind of difficult
to navigate
just gonna say it it's difficult to
navigate needs an update however
you can attach your personality to
another person's personality your
significant other or a friend
and it tells you where you're gonna have
problems so that's cool
what are your hobbies i think i'll just
end with that because i'm going to go to
therapy maybe my
therapy is my hobby it's what i do
besides work which i would recommend i
think i went through 12 therapists
before i found one that i could actually
stand
but hobbies i have hobbies i used to do
i used to write i exercise now but i
kind of hate it so that's not a hobby
podcasting is my hobby i love podcasting
podcasting is my hobby and it's also my
job
how did i manage that took a lot of work
that's how okay well i want to say
i hope you enjoyed this i hope that was
okay of me like glancing around the
camera because it's creepy just looking
directly at a camera but thank you guys
very much for
watching the show it's given me an
insane amount of opportunity
i have learned so much i've been able to
interview renowned
specialists about medical problems that
i'm trying to figure out i can't believe
how good
the work aspect of my life is like i've
have put a hell of a lot of effort into
it it hasn't just been something that
popped up it's taken hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours but
i would not be able to do this and i
absolutely love it like every time i do
a podcast if i'm in a really bad place
or if something terrible has happened
at home then i'll do a podcast and
afterwards i'll feel better because i'm
focused on somebody else
and what they're saying and it takes me
out of whatever mess i'm in
and the last five years have been crazy
and super stressful
i've been healthy but that's when my
life went crazy
in other ways at least they both didn't
happen at the same time
bad health and absurdity but
my family's been sick off and on for
five years so
it's pretty stressful and this podcast
really takes my mind
away from that so i really appreciate
you guys i like how open-minded
you are i like how disagreeable you are
and snarky
so thank you so much for your support
[Music]
you